complex regional pain syndrome or CRPS
formerly known as reflex sympathetic
dystrophy or RSD is a chronic condition
that causes persistent burning pain and
swelling in your arms hands legs or feet
your body's normal response to an injury
begins when pain receptors deliver pain
messages in the form of nerve impulses
to your brain once these impulses reach
the pain centers in your brain the pain
centers generate new impulses and send
them through your sympathetic nervous
system to the area of injury the
sympathetic impulses trigger an
inflammatory response causing blood
vessels to expand the inflammatory
response also leads to swelling and
redness in the damaged tissue as your
wound heals the swelling and redness
subside and the pain goes away
however if you have complex regional
pain syndrome the pain and swelling do
not go away after your wound heals and
may worsen over time although the exact
cause is unknown one theory suggests
that after your injury has healed
abnormal impulses continue to travel
along nerves to your skin and blood
vessels stimulating the inflammatory
response
there are two types of complex regional
pain syndrome though the symptoms are
the same for both if you have CRP s1
your condition may have been triggered
by an illness or injury but you do not
have a nerve injury in the affected area
if you have CRPS too
your condition is clearly linked to a
nerve injury in the affected area
treatment of complex regional pain
syndrome is focused on pain management
as there is no cure for this condition
your treatment options may include pain
medication physical therapy a nerve
block implantation of a pain controlling
device surgery and psychosocial support